robbed into his 42 games out of the pen
this year for the fills
well let's hope they can keep pollock
under wraps because
this is a pretty deep lineup that the
dodgers throw out even without betts and
justin turner
off the end of the bat flared to right
center segura is there one out
well objective number one check keep
turner off the base pass
the 2-2
in and out oh man it got him again
that is not a good thing
got jt again and sean picazzi and joe
girardi are heading out yeah he was
shocking if he stays in we know how
tough jt is but
that's back-to-back shots to the chops
it might be the two toughest catchers in
baseball to put up
you know to stay in games what they're
doing you know
swings at the first pitch bangs the
liner into right for a base hit
seeger now four for six in this series
and back to back two out base runners
ground ball left side tires has got it
flips over to first in time and broccoli
gets out of the inning 25 pitches
no runs one hit a couple of foul balls
off jt's mask
dodgers leave too there's the jt leaving
with paul buchheit through his head
athletic trainer friday against the
angels david faced the minimum through
four innings gave up a solo shot in the
fifth the solo shot in the six but
overall
another good audi two runs over five and
a third segora
hitting
3-14 and he pulls that one to left to
base it
he's amazing
takes a tight turn around first
here's his 02.
muncie angling over turner coming as
well they collide and nobody gets it as
long as they get to their feet
i don't know if they didn't talk or they
couldn't hear each other
max probably not used to having a second
baseman that can get over there that
fast
that is trey's ball if he wanted to call
off and be the captain of that play
they're now making sure that each other
is okay and the smiles in the
conversation tell you that they're okay
bryce home with another o2 and he gets
snapped with the change-up
david price only has one pitch that gets
a whiff percentage higher than the
league average and that's his four-seam
fastball then here the change-up finds a
swing and miss
turner to finish off his scoreless first
kind of carpeting copies team strand two
runners in scoreless first innings
getting up high though you're gonna get
it up there you better get it up out of
the zone they got it up high swing and
miss and hector picks up a strikeout
second strikeout for phil's pitching
and a strike three call
how about that he's throwing a slider he
just throws it every once in a while
yeah he's a starving rap guy he needs a
third pitch
swing at a miss he did get him with a
fastball
three strikeouts of the inning for
hector harris no runs
one hit one man left
to the bottom of the second
that's a one-two fly and a ground ball
punch to short seeger lunges to get it
strong throw and sager with a heck of a
play
together herrera it's been a great
series for corey seeger
you know they they were talking as we
went to break and alfonso marquez
decided you know what let's put the tarp
on the field as it turns out john good
move it's a good move
so we are in a rain delay for a second
consecutive night we restart things
a little after uh 10-9 here in the east
joe girardi's decision not to start kyle
gibson
has paid off because he'll start now
the line drive out to left field it's
going to stay in the yard it's going to
be off the nova care sign mccutcheon
plays it well throws to second it is in
time
welcome back catch
with a strike to gene segora it's a
single
7-4 on the put out and a little defense
bryce comes home with a 2-2 that's a
grounder to second turner will tag the
runner and throw sagurao for a double
play
really headsy play right there
think about the time it would take for
him to flip the ball to second and then
get the transfer and get it back over to
first ballinger on pitch's outer part of
the plate has been pretty good this year
that's where they're going
he lifts one to left center field back
it goes cody bellinger
wins the battle with a two-run home run
on the 13th pitch
well in this rough 20-21 that is a
crowning moment for bellinger
price to right center field that's down
and it splits the gap to the wall
that's why he hit
david price drives in matt batey
and rbi double for price and the dodgers
lead three nothing he has his first
career extra base hit this is when you
need another clutch two-out hit and make
this a one-run game
[Applause]
rolls one left center field to base it
one is in here comes gregorius he'll
score it's a 3-2 game ronald teres comes
through with a two-out basin two balls
two strikes to taylor here in the top of
the fifth inning in a 3-2 game
topped up
down the right field line harper
sprinting into foul territory there to
make the catch
on the slide
he covered a lot of ground to make sure
the fifth inning
came to a close no runs no hits
and one man left
the bazooka the lion
bouncer up the middle trey turner
got him
one two three six for brew star grad raw
smith retired for the first time tonight
it brings up seeger
grounds the first one under bowman into
right
base it for seeger to score turner and
the dodgers lead 4-2
this one goes five-fold and the dodgers
lead 5-2
monsieur to score as it gets through now
on 3-1 pollock hits a ground ball
through the box into center base yeah aj
pollock drives in corey seeger and the
dodgers with three here in the seven
6-2 lead in the ninth dodgers looking
for their fifth win out of their last
sixth game there goes smith here comes
the pitch bellinger hits it a ton
down the line it is
gone
second home run of the game for cody
bellinger
this one scraped the sky
and it opens it up it's 8-2
[Music]
got him to chase the change and that
does it
the dodgers roll the phillies again
coming out of the rain delay
you